I got t-ball I didn't you suffer were  you planning on telling me that you were  going to Canada a party till we get  there baby what I had it kicking around  I thought I put it to use it's like  you're putting a chastity belt on your  grandma where are we  I gotta be closer what are you driving  to Canada Canada the border closes and I  thought but you know what there is a  quicker way an old logging road in a  lead stream Canada we pull over a out of  this  I heard something you're crazy what if  it's a dead end  huh smart guy  Kubby it's quite a story son not a story  you're telling the truth do you think  we're all [ __ ] odds are there are  things in these woods and they are as  real as you and me and they are taking  people